taint April twelfth think we're gonna do
the Shia LaBeouf route and just do it
because we've got the destiny April
update and we've also got division
incursion mode yeah there's just updates
on updates we weren't sure they're
actually going to be on the same day but
it turns out it's going to be rough for
both of us and we're gonna have to find
time to do both let's talk about
incursion mode and we learned some of
the new details about how this is going
to work this is the free end game
content for the division so in this
mission you're going to fight against
the last man battalion and you're going
to be at a water treatment plant which
is quite huge right now because you know
it's New York it's contamination
everywhere you need water right also I
guess the big thing for them to is that
you know there is two modes to this
there's a hard mode and a challenging
mode to the incursions and it seems like
for hard mode if you're decently geared
they say you need I level 31 stuff but I
don't know if that's true whereas the
challenging mode has a required gear
score so if you don't even meet that you
can't even match make for that the thing
the big question my mind right now is
you're more of a hardcore player I think
I'm more of a casual player how did you
feel about what was shown today it's
really hard to say I think they showed
very little gameplay it did look like
the area was a lot bigger than most of
the stuff you encounter now through the
missions and the challenge modes which
is interesting they also made it a
bigger point to say you know you're
actually going to have to try to you
know spread your talents around and
build different like have different
builds which is cool because right now a
lot of people are just going like pure
dps or maybe there's one person doing
support or something like that but it
sounds like you need a more
well-balanced team which would be
interesting if that's the case so the
loot hook for incursion it seems like
right now is the for armor sets that you
can earn through different methods yeah
so the new thing that's coming in or
you're gonna get green tier stuff now
with your armors and it seems like
there's a
a set bonus that you want to hit which
is four pieces which will give you this
like amazing talent or something that we
didn't discuss so it's hard to say what
that's going to be but like you said
there's gonna be a trade-off because
with the set pieces you don't actually
get a specific talent like you would on
a high-end piece of gear so you have to
weigh okay is my high-end piece of gear
better than the set armor or do I have
enough set pieces to get these different
bonuses of which again we didn't get to
see yet but it's very Diablo like so you
know there's 51 at two and then the
major talent thing at four and then
there's y1 at six question are you going
to be making an alternate character
because it seemed like that's some of
the things you can earn you only get one
crack at a week unless you have an
alternate character yes I think the
weekly is tied kind of do the incursion
almost like a nightfall so to speak
which is interesting too because there
is no checkpoints in the incursions
which is like a knight fault or the old
style of nightfall but yeah so if you
wanted to right now you can make up to
four characters and if you're hardcore
enough and you could run the weekly four
times because the weekly which i think
is tied to the incursion gives you
whatever guaranteed loot that you're
supposed to get like the missions and
then it gives you a little bit more so
there's more incentive to do the weekly
obviously if you can and again if you
want to make four characters you can do
that you could cycle and siphon your
gear around so I guess it's not that bad
but you have to make 430 s right what I
found interesting was when they started
talking about supply drops now it's
funny because h1z1 totally tried this
and it worked to various levels this is
where a crate of high-level gear falls
out of the sky in an EVP area and
players are encouraged to fight each
other over it the part that I like about
it is I think a lot of players in the
dark zone don't feel comfortable
engaging other players like some people
are crafty and they'll screw other
players for their loot but you're never
quite sure you never like you never
allowed to give yourself full permission
to fight other players whereas it seems
like when one of these loot drops comes
out of the sky it's like okay now we're
gonna fight everybody we all understand
this and go and I think it's kind of a
relief for some of the casual players
that like yeah now I know that it's time
to fight other players I mean so the
interesting thing with the supply drops
is it's not only just other players
you're fighting over it for they're our
enemy AI it seems like that are so close
to be pretty tough and also it
interesting thing too is like it's like
a first come first serve type of
mechanic because I guess whoever gets
there first and I guess maybe clears it
out i'm not sure how the mechanism works
because i didn't really show it they
just talked about it but whoever's there
gets it first and apparently this gear
is not contaminated so like once you get
it it's yours you can't get killed for
it so I'm not really sure how that's
gonna work got any interest in trading
day yeah I think uh the trading mechanic
is good because it's like very very
similar to diablo 3 where you know when
you're cooped up you can actually drop
an item and when you drop that item
someone in your group can pick it up
within a limited amount of time it's a
two-hour window where you can trade with
you together by dropping the item so I
think it's nice because you know maybe
you're running a specific spec or
specific build that a piece of gear that
I get my really cater to you but doesn't
cater to me and I think it just gets you
to do group play more too because then
it's like okay well just cuz I don't get
something maybe my buddy gets something
that he's like oh yeah this is really
good for your build you should take this
and then you can do that and I think
trading is really good for the game and
kind of wish destiny had it all right
today so time for blunt opinions
incursion mode do you like it or you
sort of May about it I think that I like
the concept of it and I think I like the
direction they're heading into but again
since we haven't played it and since we
saw very little of it it's very hard for
me to be like oh yeah I'm all in I think
that I'm excited to play it because I
want to see something different than
what we've already experienced in the
Division I don't know how different this
is gonna be but you know me I'm all
about the loot so the fact that you're
adding set armors in and creating this
like new talent or something that only
the armors will give you is like a very
interesting concept of me and because of
that i will i am very interested in the
incursions and the set armors and
whatnot and as a casual player it's just
going to come down to really whether the
incursions are balanced for me to to
matchmake into them like on a weekly
basis and whether i can earn this are
more at like a slower pace yeah
hopefully the incursions add some
elements that interest you other like
outside of just what their been doing
and it sounds like they're starting to
test stuff and they have more incursions
that we don't know about so definitely
interested to see April told is going to
be a cluster f of shoe terday but
I think we'll just have to get our
coffees ready Aaron and you know thank
you for the conversation yeah and we'll
see you all on April twelfth
you
you